hello friends welcome back to the daily
Denny now we're counting down to the end
of 2017 and so far we showed you what
movies and music to look forward to in
2018 and now with a preview of the TV
shows were excited for next year is our
resident TV expert mr. Leanna
Baird anything back to the show and
thank you so much for having me let's
start with the shows that were missing
from 2017 but are making their
triumphant return next that sounds good
you know they say that distance makes
the heart grow fonder this is definitely
the case for these shows now Westworld
was the show that everyone was talking
about in 2016 and then it was gone gone
it was gone
because it took a long time for the show
to make and so they've been working on
it all in 2017 it's finally coming back
in spring of 2018
I cannot wait to see what happens
because you know when we left off the
host or take it over to the park that's
true and you know it'll fill that void
that is missing from Game of Thrones
thanks you're right this is very true of
course everyone also loved Atlanta now
that was from executive producer creator
and star Donald Glover and who doesn't
love him he is a hero so I'm happy to
get that FX darling back in my life
worthy yes another FX show that everyone
loves is American crime story
and so people verse OJ Simpson was a
huge Emmys and Golden Globes darling
everyone loved that show this next
season is going to be all about the
assassination of Gianna Versace there's
so many people in this show yeah you
start Penelope Cruz Ricky Martin Edgar
Ramirez the list goes on and on it's
going to be sensational and I think it's
gonna snag all the Emmys for next year
Ricky Martin's in it too right yeah I
cannot wait no I cannot laugh oh this is
my favorite show unreal was gone last
year it's finally coming back for its
third season and we are gonna connect
all with those producers as they make
their show behind the show behind the
shoulder all right BTS little BTS and
this year it's going to be a Sutra on
everlasting so Deni plenty of eye candy
for you they're not waiting with my
popcorn all right moving on to reboot
revivals and spin-offs what do you got
coming up so I love reboots your Bibles
and spin-offs but today there's a lot of
DejaVu Doug's right now so these ones
are the watch worthy gems Rosanna is
coming back to ABC the full
dysfunctional
it's coming back and it's gonna be a
good time they were at their table read
most of the original cast is in
everybody said almost all of them Johnny
Galecki is coming back as well to
reprise his role they're stealing ammo
from that great another show that is so
exciting groaning so this is a spin-off
of blackish which is the hit ABC comedy
and what I like about it is it's going
to be a spinoff on freeform that's right
the little sister network is including
the spin-off Shahidi of course is
leading that show when we talked to her
earlier this year she said they're also
gonna get into a little college angst
and a little bit of the trouble that you
would expect when you're living in the
dorm right so I can't wait to see that
for burger and of course we're gonna see
the Johnson's pop up there's a town that
I hope so we knew some Tracee Ellis Ross
up in that College yeah
we're also gonna get a Grey's Anatomy
spin-off now we don't know much about it
it's still untitled but I do know that
it's going to be centered around fire
fighters and Jason George is gonna be
back to reprise his character and let's
just say things are gonna be
yo Shonda you sound like another winner
like she's gonna set for life I mean
what can she not do pretty much and of
course something that I'm super excited
about is that Heather's is getting
review a revival into a TV show it's
coming out on paramount Network and it's
going to be a modern-day twist on the
iconic 80s flick right with three
different Heather's who are terrorizing
the school only this time they have
social media at their disposal social
media and it's not three women right now
Heather's are actually different very
different there's actually a guy Heather
as well exists out there they do I know
there's actually a new crop of shows
premiering next year what can you tell
us about what's gonna be hot there's
going to be so many new shows in 2018
you know there was over 500 new shows in
2017 yeah but these four are the ones
that I think that people will be talking
about first up we have life sentence
which is coming to the CW it stars Lucy
Hale and this is her first post pretty
little liars roll I'm loving it and it's
about a girl who has lived her whole
life with cancer she finds out that
she's cured and then she realizes that
her family's been putting up this whole
fake big happy family facade for her
this whole time so a complete 180 from
peel 180 from PLL and I'm in there it's
a really good show
good girl stunning you are gonna die
when you see this well with all the
people who are in it I'm like already
tripping out Christina Hendricks from
Mad Men we got Mae Whitman
you know from Parenthood and the dust
love it right ask for Parks and Rec
that's a dress they are amazing and it's
three regular moms who are down on their
luck they robbed a grocery store and
chaos ensues and comedy is so funny I've
seen the first two episodes
sensationally next up the sharp objects
which is coming to HBO this is the next
big little lies Denny mark my words
occur now this is starting Amy Adams and
it's already ordered eight episodes and
this is from the gone girl author
Gillian Flynn and honestly it's going to
be huge
so is this Amy Adams trying to get an
Emmy try to become it you got that right
exactly we're doing it Nicole did ik
julienne more HBO is the place to do
absolute everyone's gonna be talking
about that and they're gonna be talking
about rise which is a new drama D coming
to NBC
it's from the Friday Night Lights
executive producer Jason Katims oh yes
we all love Friday Night Lights but did
you know that Jason was also producer on
Hamilton wait what yeah what so ready
watch watch Tiny's head exposed rise is
like if you took Glee and Friday Night
Lights
and they had an amazing little baby
together it is all about a high school
and if the musical theater program Josh
Radnor from How I Met Your Mother is
trying to revitalize this musical
theater program so they have the music
from Hamilton Spring Awakening all this
great stuff it's so great and we love
Jason Katims yeah big Parenthood and
Friday Night Lights fan I'm here for
that show and Rhys will not disappoint I
can't wait you guys I wish we had an
hour service on all the TV shows that
you can expect next year so let us know
in the comments section which shows you
are most excited about and tomorrow I am
breaking down 2017 biggest music
collaborations so come back then thanks
thanks so much bye
[Music]